would all be for upcoming weddings Ascot
potentially they're all ready and
waiting in their boxes to go coronavirus
has canceled the celebration season bad
news for milliner's like joe whose
company in Luton has been making hats
for weddings and race-meetings like
Royal Ascot for more than 200 years to
try and survive until next summer they
furloughed 12th staff under a government
scheme that will pay up to 80 percent of
wages to a maximum of two and a half
thousand pounds a month it's quite a
small business so we've had to furlough
everybody the applications gone in today
and it's had a massive impact on
everybody we've been off work now I
think this is our third or fourth week
off since the government sort of said we
must shut down and everything really
slowed down for us really slowed down in
the when weddings were being cancelled
and we was just we were holding out for
Ascot but it's gone it's an
unprecedented economic intervention that
could see the government paying the
wages of more than 8 million people
online applications open today and to
relief at the Treasury were not
overwhelmed by demand as of 4 o'clock
this afternoon over a hundred and forty
thousand firms have applied and the
grants they'll receive will help pay the
wages of more than a million people a
million people who if they hadn't been
furloughed would have been at risk of
losing their job firms applying today
should receive their cash in six working
days the millinery trade gave Luton's
Football Club its nickname the Hatters
just one of hundreds of companies here
that have furloughed staff in a town
where more than 40% of workers could be
affected they include those at Vauxhall
which has furloughed the majority of its
1,600 workers having closed its nearby
plant thousands more at holiday company
chewy and easyJet hit hard by the
grounding of international travel from
huge companies like Airlines to the
smallest employers the lockdown has
sucked the life from the economy the
furlough scheme is intended to ensure it
can be revived when the
virus is under control but it has to
work otherwise millions of people could
go unpaid and businesses may face a
choice between running payrolls or going
bust
the British Chambers of Commerce says
that up to 2/3 of companies may apply
for the scheme working properly and
quickly in order to pay their people
over the coming weeks it will also be
extremely important for them to be able
to say to their banks as well that they
have payments because that would ensure
that banks would operate for parents and
possibly those businesses out as they
gain over a tricky couple of days
businesses have been told that money to
pay wages will reach their bank accounts
in six days millions of livelihoods
depend on that promise being kept poor
Celso Sky News in Luton